you all know Matt
Gates you know it was personal one more
from McCarthy this time criticizing Matt
Gates directly it's not a conservative
every look you all know Matt
Gates you know it was personal it had
nothing to do about spending it had
nothing to do about everything he
accused somebody of he was doing it all
was about getting attention from you I
mean we're getting email fundraisers
from him as he's doing it join in
quickly that's not governing that's not
becoming of a member of
Congress and regardless of what you
think I've seen the text it was all
about his ethics but that's all right
but look now I would refer you back to
that startpoint video we had of Matt
Gates back in uh March
basically saying we got these
concessions out of him and if he doesn't
act on these things we'll take him out
well Matt Gates did that McCarthy's now
basically saying it was never about that
because I acted conservatively again
point to the to the Thomas Massie thing
and this guy's in it for himself there's
a lot of rumors right now that Matt
Gates will be looking to uh run for
governor of Florida after Ron DeSantis
regardless of where desantis's
presidential campaign ends up all right
now back to Matt Gates responding to
McCarthy after responding to him to
whose benefit people have called you a
narcissist people say that is to your
benefit alone is it to the benefit of
you and to Donald Trump it's to the
benefit of this country that we have a
better Speaker of the House than Kevin
McCarthy Kevin McCarthy couldn't keep
his word he made an agreement in January
regarding the Way Washington would work
and he violated that agreement we are
$33 trillion in debt we are facing $2.2
trillion annual deficits we Face a
dollarization globally that will crush
Americans workingclass Americans Kevin
McCarthy is a feature of the swamp he
has risen to Power by collecting special
interest money and redistributing that
money in exchange for favors we are
breaking the fever now and we should
elect a speaker who's better all right
so Gates you've got your moment you got
rid of the guy you've got your moment
you got to figure out how you're going
to deal with the socialists and the wers
and the lunatics and the racists and the
rest of the Democrats and I would say
good luck with all of
that